my mom sent me she's so pissed that Kim
was dressing Caitlyn for it they asked
you Kris Jenner is not pleased with Kim
Kardashian's choice to work with Caitlyn
in this new Keeping Up with the
Kardashians super teaser the footage was
taped before Kim's robbery in Paris the
show returns on Sunday yeah what are
Kendall's worried for her health I'm
done arguing with people because I don't
feel fine and I promise you one day when
I'm rushed to the hospital then you guys
are gonna wake up and Chloe is
considering some enhancements to her
life I mean we're in LA people get their
boobs done like they fill up a car with
gas yet a girl will also get a glimpse
into the surprise DILF baby shower the
sisters threw for Rob and while kylie is
barely in the teaser the 19 year olds
had tons of fun with her niece Northwest
on Sunday okay you wanted black yeah
yep little North's got to try on Kylie
lip kit
Kylie posted this shot of nori with her
pal Ryan writing quote what happens at
auntie Kylie's stays at auntie Kylie's
do you like it Kylie was at King Cairo's
birthday party he's tagged a son with
blac Chyna Rob wished him happy birthday
on Instagram saying thank you for
letting me see what a great momma you
got that was the first thing I fell in
love with